Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. You can
call that number any time of day. It runs 24
seven and you can really say anything you want.
Now, a few things I will mention. The maximum
voicemail length is 3 minutes. We never play
three minute voicemails on the show. So if you
find that you're getting cut off by the beep
because you've used the full amount of time,
you're probably talking at least three times
longer than you should. If you swear, it probably
won't be used because then we have to bleep it,
etc.. And if you're going to criticize me, please
criticize me for things that I have actually
done or said rather than things that I haven't.
Okay. Here is someone who tuned in to one of our
streams, I guess, of a Trump speech and didn't
like how I was treating the president or the
sorry, the former. They call him the president,
the the failed former president. Of course.
Speaker 2: I was watching on your show the
Trump speech male ear. Regardless
of any political affiliation,
you were very immature and very rude.
Speaker 1:
Okay. I guess that's it. There's nothing
else. Yeah. You know, I often will get emails,
we'll cover some Trump event and folks will search
around YouTube for a live stream. And sometimes
they'll come across my live stream, during which
I comment. I give my opinion, and my opinion of
Trump is quite low. I don't think he deserves too
much praise. And as a result, people will email me
and say, How dare you disrespect the office of
the presidency and we shouldn't talk about any
president. You can't be negative. You've got to
be poor. What are you talking about? What are you
talking about? This is this. This is the United
States of America. We if if you want to talk about
decorum and tone, your real concern should be
the way in which Trump's Trump's lack of decorum
completely debased the office of the presidency
for four years. Folks are worried. I'm mean to
Trump, yet they weren't worried about
Trump mimicking a disabled reporter and
the thousands of things that he did. Give me
a break, guys. We have a fantastic bonus show
for you today. It's really a good one.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else who
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Today's bonus show, we're actually
not going to make money on, but we are going to
discuss. It turns out that that billionaire
Harlan Crowe, Clarence Thomas, his friend,
paid school tuition for some kid that wasn't isn't
Clarence Thomas his son, but that Clarence Thomas
sort of was like bothering. It's a it's yet
another really weird story involving Clarence
Thomas. Number two, Republicans are furious that
Joe Biden is sending troops to the border even
though it's what they wanted. Now they're mad
that it's happening. Okay. And we will discuss
the new Utah law that has now gone into effect,
requiring all sorts of verification to browse
pornography websites. It's wacky what is going on
socially in Utah? It's one of the most backward
states socially in the country. And we're going
to talk about that and much, much more. All of
those stories on today's bonus show, which you can
access by signing up at join Packman dot com Full
price is a great deal but you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now two four starts
now. All one word no spaces uppercase lowercase
doesn't matter 24 starts now will save you about
50% off of the cost of a membership. We'll see
you then. And then back tomorrow on the right.